[Music]
thank you
[Music]
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
tonight on Piers Morgan I'm sensible
late Queen's death but Politics on pause
now Britain wakes up to a country still
in crisis this trust tells world leaders
we've got to keep back in Ukraine we can
support for the war survive the
rocketing costs are home
I could work in just four days a week so
the surging cost of living problem we'll
debate that too
[Music]
from London this is Piers Morgan
uncensored well good evening from London
welcome to Piers Morgan uncensored in
the 12 days since great Queen Elizabeth
the second die Britain has felt very
United again it was easy to forget that
just before that happened it was
completely falling apart rocketing costs
in supermarkets food prices Energy
prices out of control
house crisis with rentals soaring
Millions fearing a bleak winter of
poverty businesses facing ruin people
fearful because violent crime was
surging we even had excrement being
tipped into our oceans at record levels
well today we felt I guess like we've
woken up with a bad headache the very
sad but also heartwarming distractions
of the last 10 days are now over
and all those problems that were there
before are sharply back in Focus they
haven't got better they've got worse
Russia's vicious war in Ukraine is
rather the heart of course there's a lot
of these problems and this trust used
her first trip as prime minister today
to tell the UN in New York that our
allies must do more she says the higher
bills are a price worth paying for
security of the world as we know it and
that may feel like it's a bitter pill to
swallow but I think she's right the UK
is spending 2.3 billion pounds this year
on weapons training and aid for Ukraine
we'll spend the same amount next year or
more at 16 times more than France the
question we should all be asking in this
country isn't why are we doing this for
the people of Ukraine but why isn't
everybody else Russia looks beleaguered
their propagandists are panicking allies
are suggesting Putin should make a deal
it's all the time to go soft on this
murderous dictator who would legally
invaded a sovereign country if Vladimir
Putin's on the ropes now's the time for
us to land The Knockout blow
well I'm joined Now by uh talktv
presenter Richard Tice and Royal author
extraordinaire Tina Brown I can't
believe anybody I'd rather have than you
Tina to wrap up this extraordinary
period in British history actually and
great to see you Richard you've been
here pretty much ever present uh from
the start and it has been truly
fascinating time I think and we'll look
back at it we'll all remember where we
were when the queen died and when these
extraordinary events rolled out
what do you make of it where are we with
all this well you know I felt coming as
I do now from New York it's like it was
like the Queen's last great Act of soft
power from dying in Scotland which
reminded them of wanting to be at the
heart of the Union perhaps again to this
last extraordinary these days where this
this crowd came together in this
incredibly beautiful way so actually the
crowd became as much of the event as as
the actual funeral became it was I mean
what struck me I've written a column
about this for the sun tonight was that
all the flash points of division
between us and this country going back
to brexit whether it's Donald Trump
brexit coveted vaccines you know
Independence in Scotland the Northern
Ireland protocols a result of brexit
being threatened and so on all these
issues which really had split families
apart I know people who literally fell
out with family members of some of these
issues they split up friendship groups
they turned us into a sort of toxic
Society fueled by social media people
taking sides on everything screaming at
each other and then we just had this
gigantic pause
when none of that mattered I don't think
anybody in these huge crowds probably
had any discussion about any of those
things it was all centered on on one
thing which was our Monarch our monarchy
and the national identity of our country
absolutely and also those incredible uh
the Traditions the richness of our
history was traumatized before our very
eyes and and suddenly you saw what
Charles was king of so from his point of
view you know the last year he has
actually been the stand-in for his
ailing mother and all of a sudden he has
he has stepped into the void left by her
and you know I thought my biggest
concern before it happened was that that
the country would just spin you know in
this sense of unbelievable loss which it
has but there has also been a
reassurance from it because you saw the
great thick so you know the richness of
these Traditions that really have this
potency and into that void stepped
Charles I mean you wrote this I mean
incredibly impressive but the palace
papers inside the house of Winds of the
truth and the turmoil on the back can
the monarchy survive
um has been answered I think this week I
think it's been answered I think King
Charles I mean Richard we've been
talking about this a lot but I think
King Charles III has got off to an
extraordinarily strong start in
reassuring us as Tina said that he has
what it takes to follow his mother
completely because what he did actually
appears he gripped it literally the
moment it happened and he reassured and
gave confidence to the nation and in a
sense he's proven that um the monarchy
is it's our constant it's our foundation
one of the key foundations of the United
Kingdom and he's proven that actually it
can survive anything and we've
celebrated and in a sense yesterday the
life of the greatest Britain yeah and
we're all privileged to be part of that
history and interestingly Tina I think
that she had the same kind of philosophy
about how to deal with challenges as the
great Sir Winston Churchill who was her
first prime minister and I suspect the
one that she had the most respect for
but his one was kbo keep buggering on uh
through World War II of course and her
version of that as we heard from Jacinda
ardern the New Zealand prime minister
when she said how did you have children
and be reigning a country and I can't
imagine she said well you just get on
with it I love that but that is so
exactly right and of course Prince
Philip always used to say look up look
out say let's do more and I love that
philosophy and that was of course the
Queen's philosophy all along never
complained never explain don't give
interviews don't show too much of your
own self you don't need to and actually
the less they showed her and her mother
the Queen Mother I mean all the queen
mother ever had to do was stay in London
during the Blitz and not leave to safety
she could have done and then go down to
the East End and stand in the rubble and
say I'm here for you and the public
never ever forgot that they loved her
from that moment I think I think very
similar to that was the sort of wordless
rebuke if you like of the way the queen
has sat alone
obeying the coveted rules
you know in Winter blame the rules that
the people who were setting them the
night before correct were breaking with
two illicit parties at number 10 downers
and there's something about the
juxtaposition of those facts I think
when when people read about the Downing
Street parties they remembered the queen
sitting there alone and it was such a
thing Boris Johnson actually I think he
would have survived party gave it hadn't
been I think for the harrowing image of
a lonely Queen mourning the rock of her
life because she felt a duty to obey the
rules that the person who'd made them
and his team were breaking the such
thing and she couldn't visit him for six
weeks in hospital yeah the agony of that
for her because they never thought about
jumping the chair probably couldn't jump
the queue and we'll come to that later
probably could have done she's the queen
but she decided she would never do what
her people weren't allowed to do it
reinforced the difference between a
monarchy the queen and the Duke of
Edinburgh they always delivered they
performed and performed they just got on
with it they rolled this sleeves up they
worked hard and hard and hard and it was
never in doubt and I think I think
that's what King Charles will now show
us he's been out there he's been meeting
people he's been visible and I think we
should actually be full of confidence
one of the other rookies that we now
have as a country not just a new king
but we have a new prime minister and
this trust has gone on her first foreign
trip to New York for the United Nations
General Assembly huge Gathering of world
leaders many of whom will have come
straight from London where they had
attended the funeral well joining me now
from New York is talk to the people of
the Kate McCann uh okay you've actually
had an interview with prime minister
trust today in New York a lot of lines
coming out of your interview and other
interviews she's given the central theme
of which appears to be that she is going
to plow her own way through this
economic crisis and she understands
there may be risk but she thinks it's
time for bold decision making and that
appears to be a tax cutting agenda and
one in which she's not going to punish
Bankers or energy bosses
yeah I think peers less trust his
answers on those questions particularly
on the idea of lifting the cap on
Bankers bonuses are absolutely
fascinating because you're right what it
shows is she's setting the tone as the
new prime minister as somebody who she
says isn't afraid to stick up for what
our unpopular policies if she thinks
that they will deliver growth in the
economy now the first of those I
mentioned Bankers bonuses that could
welcome as soon as Friday she confirmed
there will be a fiscal event the
chancellor will set out more information
on the energy plans and more in that
so-called mini budget but there are much
bigger issues too I asked her for
example about grammar schools and about
lifting planning regulation regulations
and she said no more caps no more
targets rather on planning and she
indicated that she would go ahead with
plans for more grammar schools and if
some of those policies are unpopular but
they are also things that list trust has
made her name on as a politician over
the last sort of decade or so if she
does pursue those policies then she runs
a risk because every economic decision
she makes but kindly the ones that will
add to the debt burden will have an
impact on interest rates and that could
really affect all of us if you like
peers there's a little bit of a Race
Against Time going on here so one of the
questions I asked her today was whether
she could guarantee that she wouldn't
crash the economy when she's inside
number 10. in fact I asked her twice
have a listen to what she said
so can you guarantee now to the British
public that the economy will not crash
on your watch well
what I can tell people is every single
measure we take is about getting the
British economy growing but also making
sure that we are economically secure and
one of the reasons that we're facing
these energy price hikes is that we
became too dependent on the global
market for energy so we need to build
our long-term energy resilience I want
us to be a net energy exporter by 2040
so we are taking the long-term steps
that will get Britain back on track and
make sure we're not just a growing
economy but we're also a secure economy
that isn't dependent on Authority is
that a yes that's a guarantee well I'm
not one whoever predicts the future but
what I can say is the measures we take
will help us weather this very difficult
storm we're facing and also put in place
the long-term building blocks to make
sure our country is successful in the
future
I mean she's being pretty cautious there
and I think understandably because many
economists think she's taking a hell of
a gamble with the nation's finances I've
just seen a tweet from her president
macra and I committed to working
together to end Reliance on Russian
energy deepening cooperation to reduce
volatility in the market and cut costs
for households the problem she's got and
I think you said Mr I think in another
clip I saw is that she doesn't have much
time to do any of this she's got to move
very very quickly a to avert a complete
financial disaster this winter
for people up and down the country but
also because the uncertainty in Ukraine
she's committed to that I applaud her
for that we don't know how that's all
going to go and then she's got an
election ticking away within two years
so it's very difficult to build any kind
of agenda as a new prime minister isn't
it when you don't have much time she's
got to really go for it
yeah and of course all that against the
backdrop of a weak pound the Northern
Ireland protocol which needs to be
renegotiated a huge problem with Channel
migrant Crossings which by the way the
Northern Ireland protocol and
immigration neither of those issues came
up in her conversation with president
macron today that certainly raised some
eyebrows and led to questions about
whether Liz truss is trying to make sure
it's smooth sailing over here in the
early days of her first visit to Unger
and then potentially those difficult
issues will be ironed out later on but
they are going to be really difficult
and the huge meeting tomorrow with
President Biden the one that's been
rescheduled remember again raising some
eyebrows one of the things that she's
going to have to try and focus on there
is the Northern Ireland protocol
President Biden has said he wants to
bring that up but they are in very
different places on that particular
issue and today appears just as I was
asking let's trust those questions about
the economy President Biden tweeted he
was second tired of trickle-down
Economics something she has said she
really firmly believes in now that is
being ruled out as a direct comment on
Liz trusses policies by AIDS here in New
York but it's not going to be an easy
meeting I think there's going to be a
lot that those two have to try and sort
out between them well one thing they
won't be discussing is any trade deal
between the UK and the US which we were
told was all absolutely ready one of
boris's great promises oh it's all there
it'll be it'll probably take several
seconds for this to all be delivered no
chance of that happening under President
budge he's made it Crystal clears just
bottom of the tray and I'm mindful of
going back to President Obama who said
we were back of the back of the queue
um and that certainly seems to be the
case and that's not good for a country
which is split from the European Union
and had as one of its big selling cards
actually the best thing about brexit we
can do with spanking new trade deal with
the Americans they're not interested
yeah and I think the comments from Liz
truss when she was flying into New York
on the plane over overnight were
designed to set expectations on that
front because she said very clearly
there would be no trade deal in the
short to medium term now you're right in
a way President Biden had already put
that off the table but Liz trust saying
that just before she landed here is an
indication that she doesn't want it to
be seen as her turning up putting out
her hand for a little bit of help on a
trade deal and getting it slapped firmly
away now the issue come back to it is
Northern Ireland that's what's been
linked with trade that's why this is
difficult there are other issues around
that diplomatic ones here about the way
the two countries see free trade what's
beneficial and what isn't but it is an
indication of the so-called special
relationship just how special is it and
peers we love to analyze this don't
we've got a new prime minister we always
want to look in the margins to see how
they react to one another but that will
be fascinating tomorrow to see how warm
their handshake is whether they are
smiling when they come out of that
meeting and whether they can agree on
how well it went because they need to
move from there and of course it's not
some point there will be a formal visit
from President Biden to the UK in one
Liz trust heading to Washington Kevin
County New York uh thank you very much
we'll be back with you tomorrow I'm sure
it'll be fascinating a few days out
there for Liz trust not least with the
American president so I appreciate you
joining us your reaction uh just
generally uh Tina to Liz trust he's
being Builders the new Thatcher yeah
um what do you think I mean it's a huge
challenge obviously first of all I think
she has a sudden kind of it's like she's
eaten Alice's eat me cake today because
she's had this huge massive you know
greeting of Biden and so on in in the
context of the of the uh of the funeral
where he was like one of these big
leaders at the palace and she was like
part of all of this now she's in New
York America and suddenly she's like
back to being like not the most
important thing in Biden's inbox so
that's for her must be a bit sort of
whiplash I mean in terms of of
um Maggie and and Liz because you knew
Maggie though I've definitely met chat
Maggie I met her first actually in the
70s when she was still just leader of
the Tory parties just come and I met her
at the house of Woodrow Wyatt you know
the yeah I said boy would dry indeed and
um at the point where those days because
people still did this they said that all
the women were going to leave the table
leaving the men to discuss serious
matters and have their port we the women
me one of them left the table and to buy
complete consternation Maggie stayed
behind
so we were just like completely kind of
a pool no of course I think she was
absolutely right I mean you know the
hell with this yeah you know stay with
the men and we should have all stayed
absolutely she was the Trailblazer that
kind of stuff sticking it to all the men
uh a whole fire I'm gonna have a short
break and be right back to talk about
other issues today you mentioned
President Biden he was so far back in
the Abbey almost got a nosebleed uh why
was the American president reduced to
the mere ranks of Mortals at such a
world event we'll discuss that also this
issue of British Hue jumping would you
jump
an EQ we'll be discussing the Fallout
from Holly and Phil which has been
gripping the country today
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to Pittsburgh I'm rejoined
by talking to you presenter original
Titus Royal author Tina Brown who took
the palace paper I would imagine this is
selling my hot cakes
there'll be a few more pearl necklaces
for you Tina Brown um but it's a great
I'm ready on hold it's a fantastically
juicy but I even enjoyed the bits where
you ever go at me mainly because it's
driving me in such a fascinating way I
thought this guy sounds riveting then I
realized it was me
um
an interesting thing wasn't it the
protocol at the at the Abbey for all the
world leaders President Biden comes in
and I assumed he'd be right at the front
not a bit of it he was like halfway down
the back which can never happen to
people of his stature in that position
we've got I think we've got footage of
of President Biden coming in and then
sort of directed into the middle have we
got that footage
I can't I there we are um this is where
he puts up I mean way behind and it
turned out the explanation was that the
president doesn't have uh any uh further
status at this particular Royal uh
funeral event uh over other members of
royal families and also over members
leaders of commonwealth countries so
Jacinda ardern and others were ahead of
him which must have been I mean Justin
Trudeau was like first time he's ever
been ahead at any event the United
States president what do you make of
that is this right or should we have
talked about protocol I mean come on is
he American no I think I love it because
it was like this was the monarchy show
this is the way that monarchy was doing
it this was the Queen's funeral and for
her her cousins all of these Royal Crown
heads and of course her beloved
Commonwealth they took precedence Donald
Trump you'll be unsurprised to hear was
completely graceless about this and said
uh in a in a message on his own social
media platform in real estate like in
politics and in life location is
everything
and there's no way Donald Trump would
have been that far back I think it was
about row 14 or 15. I think he wouldn't
look even more than normal I think he
would have been doesn't matter how much
you have to buff that is the protocol
you know I have to say that I could not
help but think that the day after this
funeral Trump was dictating a memo to
his kids saying I want a funeral like
this but bigger yes okay I want to feel
like this but bigger on General Behavior
Uh the Canadian uh prime minister Justin
Trudeau is probably the wokest world
leader in the history of world leaders
uh and yet constantly gets caught doing
things like blackface everything else
he's a ranking the group anyway uh he
was taught I think a day or a day before
the funeral uh actually singing Bohemian
Rhapsody by Queen in his Hotel bar oh I
think we got a picture of this
let's see if we can listen to a bit of
it here we go
foreign
[Music]
Canada's Got Talent but I did Judge
Britain and America's Got Talent and if
I had that he's getting a big red buzzer
because that was a tuned as wailing of
historic proportions I guess it's the
questions either shouldn't have been
doing this as a world leader on the eve
of the queen well here's the thing I
mean we are now living in the tech talk
area I mean we're living in The Tick
Tock area this is one of the things that
Charles is going to have to confront his
mother came to you know the throne at a
time when you know it was the culture of
deference and you know although actually
she it did coincide the Queen's
coronation with the Advent of Television
right coronation was the first big event
televised it was but it was most
reverential everything was reverential
now Charles comes to power you know at a
time when you know everything's up for
grabs and so you never have a private
moment I mean frankly I liked him for
doing that I mean at funerals everybody
kind of releases tension by getting
drunk and having you know and having
songs and all the rest of it it just
said it shouldn't have been caught on
camera what about this it was deliberate
I mean unless actually he said that I
think it's cool yeah I mean thank you
for the new Freddie Mercury maybe he's
got a personality afterwards it's just
remarkable I'm not a Trudeau fan at all
but uh yeah as you say he wouldn't win
any prizes for a singer what do we think
of this uh well two things the queue
right first of all and then the queue
jumpers has become a huge Scandal
um pretty overblown in my view but the
cue first of all what does it tell you
Tina about brick when he came back and
saw you've been spending a lot of time
in America in the last few decades when
he saw that cue well what you saw was
that the queue had become a sense the
people's own give back to the queen so I
mean person after person said the same
thing after 70 after her giving us 70
years of Duty it was the least I could
do so the queue became this act of of
gift to the queen waiting so I actually
reflected I think and again I wrote this
in my song column I think it reflected
all the virtues of the queen yeah
resilience hard work determination
courage you know humility doing
something for somebody else not yourself
and talking to strangers talking to
strangers and getting on with it
it was it was the personification of all
things which actually made this country
great which I think we should be looking
to get back into oh completely I mean I
joined it I was I was lucky it was only
five and a half hours but you did you
you get to the back of the queue and and
you start talking to people and you
start chatting you make friendships and
it really was it was the Brits lover
Cube but this was the queue of all cues
and I think there was something
just rather rather special about so some
people some very famous people joined
the back of the queue David Beckham
famously joined the back of the queue
and whether you're cynical about his
motivation it went down very well with
people that he didn't take a a VIP route
like President Biden and others who of
course weren't able to do that but there
were people like uh Holly Willoughby and
philosopher who front this morning are
the big programs in this country
obviously
um who it took advantage of an
opportunity for journalists I know
Richard your own partner Isabel is
defending herself and doing the same
thing and actually put up a pretty good
defense
um but here they are uh going down what
was a sort of VIP line
adjacent to where the public were going
and of course not having to queue now
all hell broke Liz about this they've
been the subject of it I think I'm
ridiculously over the top campaign
there's 20 000 people have signed a
petition now than five of course they
shouldn't be fired it's ridiculous it
may have been a misjudgment I said
myself on the show I don't think anyone
should have been jumping the cube full
stop wherever you are unless you're a
world leader and you just obviously
there's a Time issue
um they they went on the program this
morning and said this Holly said this on
the program today
the rules were that we would be quickly
escorted around the edges to a platform
at the back in contrast those paying
respects walked along a carpeted area
beside the coffin and were given time to
pause none of the broadcasters and
journalists there took anyone's place in
the queue and no one filed past the
Queen We of course respected those rules
however we realized that it may have
looked like something else and therefore
totally understand the reaction please
know that we would never jump a queue
what are you making full disclosure I'm
a good friend of Hollies I feel very
sorry she's absolutely distraught I
think about the reaction no well it's
true and genuinely there was a clearly
in the head a blurring of the line about
work if you're working and you're
covering it I think a lot of journalists
went through there Isabelle did I know
other journalists who did it and haven't
been subjected to all this but is it the
old-fashioned thing the British are the
best at queuing in the world right to
the point somebody tries to jump in
right well it just also became like this
it grew that feeling as the days went by
you know so suddenly now it became like
at the end it became like you know
cutting a Queue at Mecca you know
because it was so long because it was so
arduous and there were veterans and 90
year olds and so on right it was the
statement the whole The Waiting was the
statement itself and that's why it kind
of got as it did but you know these
things kind of take off as we know you
remember during Diana's funeral when
suddenly there was that whole thing
about where's the where's the flag on
top of Buckingham's house
demanding they lower it that's right and
so things like that they build and they
have to they get very cathartic Richard
I mean Theresa May jumped the queue and
nobody seemed to bat an eyelid um other
politician Angela Raynor I think the
labor Deputy leader she jumped the queue
um you didn't you you queued actually I
queued I was I was your own partnership
you were split down the middle we took a
very different view on it and you know
what was your view my view was I wanted
to join the queue I wanted to to be
there to experience it and to go through
it and you've no idea frankly whether
it's going to be two hours five hassle
or ten hours but I was there and there
were moments where you think wow this is
a real thing and but look I loved it I
don't regret it for a minute and you
know the drawers of Technology you could
work a bit on the old smartphone and
whatever that's fine
um so but you know other people took a
different view Holly and and Philip look
in a sense they made a judgment and it's
turned out to be a misjudgment yeah I
don't think they I don't think there's
nothing flogging that's going on I think
it's got a better MPS did not need four
passes maybe one for the other half but
they didn't need four parts yeah I mean
I think they actually it was there have
been some funny memes about this
Domino's Pizzas put out a tweet
so they were going to be delivering
sorry for any apologies for my weight
team but they've just taken an order
from Holly and Phil and actually the
best thing they can probably both do is
just have a laugh about it get on with
it now I don't think anyone yeah the
Venom of social media I've been in the
receiving end you know I used to do a
Morning Show before them
um in the next door Studio I had to
vacate mine for not believing old
princess Pinocchio I mean the world's
gone nuts so I say that
just switch gears now um this is
kovit which has gone the president of
the United States says that uh the
pandemic is over that's been challenged
by his own medical experts you say it's
too early to say that but certainly life
feels pretty normal I mean I was
thinking uh yesterday we were talking
about this imagine if this had happened
in the middle of the pandemic the first
wave right
um but what was interesting uh is how
some other countries have dealt with
covid and China in particular which was
of course almost certainly the source of
it
um has this extreme Draconian zero
covered policy to this day and there
have been the most alarming things
happening and it's been crystallized by
a bus a quarantine bus taking 27 people
on route to a remote location uh in one
of the provinces it's sparked a complete
outrage because it crashed and they were
all killed but in probably the question
well why are they being taken to these
to these quarantine camps
um you're also seeing Clips like this is
the Chinese social media showing people
fleeing a Superman Market in Shanghai
this is to avoid being locked down after
a positive Kobe case was traced in the
store when that happens they locked the
store and you could be stuck in there
for several days China's been building
endless quarantine camps vast categories
this is where they send people who test
positive for covid that's where that
that bus was going when he crashed and
killed and everybody in there
um so it's been an extraordinary thing
to observe there's also people who you
have to have a covered test uh to be
negative if we can go outside in many
parts of China and some people are
queuing in utterly torrential rain for
hours on end to have a covid test
praying that they come up negative so
they can actually step outside this is
in mythical bed and where we are in this
country
um I'm joined that by by sending you
from The Spectator who's an expert on
all things China Cindy what do you make
of this and what is what's going on in
China
well it's really heartbreaking peers
because as you say we here in the UK are
pretty much back to normal and actually
a lot of the world is um obviously that
for us has come at a high price of a
really extraordinary death toll which
China hasn't seen but we now have
normality back and for my friends and
family in China they could be locked
down at you know within the space of a
few hours that some cities have been
locked down at just because of a few
cases in cities of tens of millions of
people because of this zero covert
policy where many no no cases will ever
be tolerated and so you're seeing these
very distressing
um imagery you're seeing this horrible
bus crash
um and it's really really sad actually
that you know that China still hasn't
managed to get out of it is there a more
Sinister thing going on here involving
an authoritarian regime wanting to exert
control over its people and using this
as an excuse
well look there's certainly local
governments who have used this as an
excuse because um in China these days
you need to kind of app a health app to
show that you've not been to anywhere
any regions that have covert outbreaks
and if you're if you've got a red code
on that app you can't go into public
spaces and we have seen cases where
local governments have used that to
control where people can go so that they
can't go protest against for example
Financial scams in a different country
so it has been taken advantage of but I
think from an essential government it's
actually just because they don't know
what else to do they haven't vaccinated
to this same extent the vaccines are not
as good as the ones that we have been
lucky enough to have and so if they
opened up it would be an absolutely
tragic scenes across the country and
bear in mind that's his imping in a
month's time is facing a renewal of his
time limit so he can have another five
ten years in power at least and so he's
not going to want to take any risks and
so we are seeing the people in a holding
pattern because the central government
has basically screwed this one up yeah
and of course very little global empathy
because people think well you lot
started this in China you probably
covered it all up didn't tell people
quick enough so actually you reap what
you sow which is not as horrible for the
Chinese people but there will be very
little sympathy around the world for
that and they'll also be a real question
marks now about how China has handled
this pandemic and how it ever ends I
mean if you operate a zero covered
policy for that number of people over
you know one and a half billion people
where does it ever end I don't see how
it does uh Cindy thank you for joining
me your broadcast editor a spectator
um really appreciate you joining me at
late notice today so thank you very much
we're going to come back and get your
reaction to that because it is
extraordinary isn't it and we're also
going to talk uh about this big issue uh
Ukraine do we continue to fund Ukraine
with arms with help to get them over the
line against Vladimir Putin and the
Russians or should the priority for
Britain be the cost of living crisis
it's a big debate people have strong
views about it both ways we'll talk
about that after the brexit
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
this is talk TV
[Music]
welcome back to Pittsburgh it's a war in
Ukraine weight rages on the prime
minister is committed to spending 2.3
billion pounds more in military aid as
the cost of living crisis bites here
very hard some people will be thinking
we should be prioritizing the issues
back here on the domestic front not
supporting the ukrainians in their
battle with the Russians well joining me
now to discuss this is the Heritage
party David Kurt plus Richard Tice and
Tina Brown the former advisor to
Ukrainian foreign Ministry uh Cormac
Smith before we get to Ukraine to really
get your reaction seated to the
situation in China my mother just has
messaged me with a rather good question
are we sure the Chinese don't know
something about Kobe that we don't which
actually is quite terrifying that's
that's a whole movie I don't even want
to think about that I mean you feel I
feel it's a terrifying demonstration of
authoritarian Madness yeah and here's
she who's going first third term by the
way when they get to their third terms
they always go completely they do as I
can see like British prime ministers
they all go nuts they all go crazy so
he's gone crazy with this um in a way it
actually does sort of dovetail him with
Ukraine because that's what we're
fighting about in Ukraine yeah we you
know Putin also is a man who cannot
admit his role that's the point
president G he cannot admit he's wrong
and he cannot admit that he's got a Duff
vaccine right and that's the biggest
problem because they have not jammed
certainly a lot of the older people have
just not been vaccinated so he's he's
LED himself into a terrible yeah
terrible position and it affects all of
us because their economy is in trouble
it means we've got higher inflation all
over the world and you know so it does
still continue to affect all of us yeah
I mean we had a family wedding uh last
weekend load of people went down my dad
my brother my uncle and they've all had
a rough few days of a bad cold and
they're all recovering well that's what
vaccines have done to this virus and
that's what the Chinese are not getting
because their vaccines aren't as good
um so this turns Ukraine let me go to
call Max Smith first of all the former
advisor to Ukrainian foreign Ministry
let's trust new British prime minister
has determined as Boris Johnson their
predecessor to offer full support from
this country uh to Ukraine in this
battle with Russia uh presumably you
would support that
Pierce first thank you very much for
having me on yes I would support it
absolutely there's two things I'd like
to say Pierce first is we have a moral
obligation to support Ukraine this is
the most this is the most diabolical Act
of aggression against a sovereign and
peaceful country that we have seen on
European soil since 1939 to 1945 there
is no doubt about it Putin is the Hitler
of the 21st century you know I don't
need to retell the horrible atrocities
that Russian troops have been carried
out have been carrying out in Ukraine
but secondly even if we don't have a
moral compass and feel that we have a
moral obligation to this you know it's
in our interest Russia has been waging a
hybrid war against the West for almost a
decade certainly since the illegal
annexation of Crimea and you know we
weren't listening in 22 17 when Sergey
lavrov went to the Munich security
conference and he celebrated the um the
the the coming asunder of the post-war
order which you know has given us the
greatest period of Peace
this is completely the point as far as
I'm concerned but David Kern from the
Heritage party you don't agree why no I
don't agree I mean what Cormac is not
saying is that the West has been poking
the bear for eight years essentially and
the Ukrainian Army and forces that's why
I'm part of them
Democratic the Ukrainian Force the
Ukrainian forces for eight years have
been shelling naming killing Russian
ethnic Russians
actually in the osce
Russian people have been killed by the
azov Battalion forces which are part of
the Ukrainian is Justified what he's
doing I think is trying to protect the
ethnic Russians in the east
is that the analogous to the situation
in Kosovo in the 90s and the West
supported Kosovo coming out of you
coming out of Serbia I'm not saying that
we want this war we could have sat down
at the beginning this in February and we
could have avoided
they wouldn't have had to do that we
could have just had a negotiation and
not been poking the bear says you know
why quite fantasy Latvia
well that's conjecture he's not he's
well you know how he's thinking what he
said I mean they they don't call this
they call this a special operation at
the moment
well we're not at war no one in the west
has declared war on Russia as well
because we don't want to get into the
war between the weapons declared war on
a completely unaggressive country in
terms of Ukraine they were just trying
to defend themselves I think it's
enormously arrogant when when people say
you know they should sit down at the
negotiating table and just well what
negotiation what is there to give up
there is nothing to trade I mean Putin
wants to take a big slice a big hunk out
of ukrainians
be under No Illusion Putin wants a whole
of Ukraine he thinks it should never
have been seeded he thinks the Soviet
Union should never be broken up he's on
record of saying it was a National
Disgrace that's why he didn't go to
Gorbachev's funeral recently and he
wants the whole thing back he wants to
restore the Soviet Union he wants to be
a czar he hasn't said that he's relying
by the way he's relying on people like
you to speak just to find what he's
doing is a sovereign
opinion and I think that we should be
trying to end this peacefully because
what's happening now
I've never been to you right yeah I mean
what's I think what's disturbing to a
lot of people today
is saying she's going to send 2.3
billion pounds in Lethal Aid to Ukraine
in order to continue on prolonging this
concept actually no we don't need to try
and defeat it which will actually
resolve this whole energy crisis
what do you want right now
because actually I do want regime change
we should be de-escalating
people
timeout let's take a short break we'll
come back we're going to continue Mr Bay
because actually it's getting
interesting
not comfortable
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
well back to Pittsburgh we had a rather
Lively end to that last segment we've
had to lose two of our guests who were
due to leave so they've gone my thanks
to Tina Brown and Cormac Smith but we've
kept David Curtin with his rather in my
opinion incended reviews about Ukraine
and Richard Tyson probably shares My
Views but let's let's try and get
through this so David Curtin your
position is that we poached the Russian
bear and therefore Ukraine is reaping
what we sowed
um partly yes because we supported
Ukrainian forces including Neo-Nazi
battalions like the adoth Battalion like
the right sector for eight years who
were shelling killing Russians in the
donbass area the Donetsk and luhan's
people you mean after Russia seized they
didn't they well they they had a
referendum well and they decided to join
Russia and they were part of actually
Russia until the 1950s they were just
added to Ukraine later on in the time of
Khrushchev they weren't all so you don't
respect the breakup of the Soviet Union
you think it shouldn't have happened no
I do I do think that's a good thing
because I don't expect you I don't
support the Soviet Union
give back the land not at all what it
has democratically went for itself and
has voted to keep as I said in the last
segment we supported Kosovo when they
wanted to leave Serbia Crimea wanted to
leave Ukraine it's exactly the same
situation they had a reference
the simple fact is that Putin's Russia
invaded a sovereign state interestingly
the only part of its border on that
western side that's not a member of NATO
and I think that is a key point he
didn't dare touch NATO so he's gone into
Ukraine you can't say that he's sort of
protecting Russian people he's gone into
someone else's sovereign state he's
murdered women children in the most and
men in the most Barbarian by the way
Ukraine Ukraine everyone thought the
Ukraine would roll over Ukraine has put
up an unbelievable resistance and when I
went there and interviewed president
zielinski you could feel it amongst
every one of them they would determined
not to give the Russians an inch of
their land interestingly Vladimir Putin
was due to address the Russian Nation
today it's now been delayed until
tomorrow rumors swirling about what he
may be trying to do is he going to
declare war is he going to mobilize the
Russian people which comes if you could
if you declare war
the reason the ukrainians are doing so
well apart from their incredible courage
is because of the wild support is the
weapons that we in the United States
notably numb not from other European
countries like Germany but those were
weapons have made a massive massive my
problem David with your with your in my
opinion rather naive take on this is
that if you think Vladimir Putin If he
if he succeeds in what he wants in
Ukraine grabbing the donbass to add to
Crimea at the very least
he's going to stop there is for the
birds this guy wants to restore the
Soviet Union it's not going to stop with
a bit of Ukraine no I think he will
because I mean they told you that he
stated beforehand exactly what he wants
is going to do he wants to demilitarize
Ukraine he wanted to denounceify that
see what his words
president is Jewish right this idea that
he supported this idea
what you're saying what's your saying
what you're saying is exactly the kind
of propaganda that is spewed up by
Russian State media every single day
that this is Justified because the
ukrainians are a bunch of Nazis their
president is Jewish they lost family
members in the Holocaust but that's
nothing to do with what's happening
today
this is Vladimir Putin standing up to a
bunch of Nazis it's completely
absolutely is funded by an oligarch
called uh
peers is saying that I'm sort of pumping
out Russia you are you're spewing
Russian propaganda you are I do not want
this conflict to go on I don't want to
escalate it
because the the people in the donbass
region and the Crimea are ethnic
Russians and they would you know what
percentage of people in the donbass
actually consider themselves that they
want to be Russian 100 and the Donetsk
and enhance People's Republic absolute
nonsense no that is the fact I mean you
can say it's nonsense
essentially the people in the donbass
that want to go back to of being Russian
the people in the areas what percentage
of the Don bat you know from the poll
100
nonsense eight percent want to be
Russian again well I think people eight
percent can sort of check you say 100.
Obviously you know in those areas in the
east and south of Ukraine there's always
been a majority of ethnic Russians in
the Western Center of Ukraine has always
been a majority of people in the domest
have no desire which is why they're
fighting every single day they're
risking their lives to stop the Russians
back a lot of territory because they're
beginning to win this battle this war
they have encouraged you cannot
negotiate with a brutal bullying
dictator history has littered with those
examples the greatest most horrific of
all was Hitler and you think that you
can sort of negotiate with Putin forget
it he's a bully you have to stand up to
bullets Rock Solid firm and you have to
push it in and that is what is happening
at the moment and when you're talking
about narcification what Putin's been
doing in Ukraine is utter notification
that's what he's been doing he's been
behaving like a like Adolf Hitler babe
in 1939 and that's why it's incumbent on
the World to stop him and why I applaud
Liz truss for continuing the good work
of Boris Johnson in this area of leading
the way in Europe to help the ukrainians
win this war thank you for joining us I
appreciate it thank you Mr Tice that's
it for me uh we'll be about the same
time tomorrow night good night and
remember keep it unsensitive
[Music]
I'm telling you've done and this is talk
TV the most memorable moment in my
career without sounding completely
conceited has to be interviewing
president Trump in the open Office in
the White House particularly little red
button he had on his desk I have no idea
what he did his instrumental I wanted
more rules for the launch of nuclear
strike on North Korea or open up a sharp
pit that I've been Fallen to turn out he
pressed it right at the end of the
interview and didn't walk to Butler with
a tray and carrying it down it was the
dicober
this is talk TV news
good evening I'm Nadira Tudor Liz truss
has told talk TVs the news desk she's
willing to be unpopular in order to
bring in measures that she thinks will
grow the economy the new prime minister
has admitted that her tax cuts will
disproportionately benefit the rich but
also confirmed that she'll reverse the
National Insurance hike a planned speech
by Vladimir Putin has been delayed until
tomorrow according to his former advisor
the Russian presidents expected to speak
about planned referendums in four
occupied regions of Ukraine which could
allow them to vote to become part of
Russia NATO is called the votes a sham
and flowers left in tribute to the late
Queen will be composted and given a new
lease of life in planting projects
across the Royal Parks work to remove
items laid by the public is expected to
begin on Monday that's all for now we'll
have more after the talk
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]